please  look to the stars  to discover who we are  of course that is from the current star  trek show but the franchise is  celebrating  55 years of hope and adventure mark your  calendar september 8th is going to be  known as star trek day paramount plus  will be streaming live stream panels  conversation with cast members some of  the creative brains behind the star trek  universe and they're telling us to be  prepared for surprise announcements mika  burton will wheaton who is from the next  generation will be the host the very  first episode of star trek aired on  september 8th  in  1966.  so live long and prosper john it was  only on for a couple of seasons right it  wasn't on that long no but the movies  and everything else well it became a  cult favorite oh yeah and then it just  went crazy from there yes it became a  cult favorite that's my william shatner  impression i'm a traffic guy not a  doctor